thank you yasser yes we are indeed with
alice lee alice first of all tell us how
does it feel after the first two games
you played a much more experienced
opponent and you managed to hold two
very intense draws how does that feel
well
i haven't seen the evaluation of this
game but uh yesterday's game was um yeah
very intense it was like kind of up and
down but
this game i feel like i was kind of
pressing so i mean i'm not sure if a
draw was particularly great
but like of course i don't know the
evaluation yet
but of course it's great to at least
not have lost yesterday's game because
that was a pretty big struggle
and of course it's an honor to be here
you're going to go into a playoff in the
next few minutes how do you approach
that and what do you think your chances
are
i'm not sure my chances because this is
very different from the slow chess
especially
with that rapid time control almost
blitz
um
i'd say it's probably like 50 50
because like anything can happen really
a very confident alice lee thank you
very much for joining us in the studio
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next few minutes thank you
good luck alice in your playoff indeed
inspiring